here we are another boring tourist  advertise without Rochford wall but it  isn't just another 16th century house  it's the past time available in a once  loyal queen and it now houses the spirit  it also used to be inhabited by British  military forces during both world wars  it was engulfed by flames leaving the  Attic decay it may be rebuilt but the  Heritage Days along with the ghosts and  those who are food so why would you  visit discover a history with guided  tours or 30 seconds more your thing join  our night ghost hunting come and explore  you never know what you might find  search Rochford whole calm for /  inquiries to find out more